welcome back to las vegas now we like to
say that diamonds are everyone's best
friend right well on september 8th it's
time to break out the sparkles and get
ready for dress for success of southern
nevada's 10th annual diamond date and
here to tell us all about it we have the
executive director norman triago
alongside darlene miller the owner of mj
christensen diamonds the main partner
for the event ladies thank you for being
here
i'm very excited i just joined the board
for just for success this is my first
diamond dig so norma i'll start with you
tell us a little bit about diamond dig
and what that means it sounds like so
much fun oh it's a fabulous event i'm so
happy to share with your audience this
year's diamond dig
is taking place at the goose island
lounge in the t-mobile arena it's going
to be fabulous
we're going to have two dig tables
we're going to talk a little bit about
the fabulous prices they're going to be
so many fun activations a treasure chest
a bubble bar grab i'm excited
music amazing food a signature diamond
cocktail and all for an amazing cause to
help empower women to be economically
independent so let women have that
economic status that we need here across
the las vegas valley and you guys are
going big for the ten year and you
actually do dig for diamonds tell us
about how that works yes
uh we're gonna have two dig tables in it
we're gonna have gemstones uh as well as
a fabulous uh grand prize you wanna talk
about that amazing grand i i do well
they've stepped it up this year and so
we're going to have two as she said
sandboxes
so we'll have about 30 gemstones that
natural gemstones that can be discovered
in sand they'll also have other items
you know that for prices that can be won
but the grand prize winner and and we'll
have two because we have two sandboxes
yes is a beautiful diamond um circle
halo pendant
and so each winner of each sandbox gets
one of those that sounds amazing and you
have been part of this since the very
beginning how does it feel to be a
partner and to have seen it grow over
the years well you know when we started
about about 10 11 years i guess we had
to skip one um it was in our store you
know and it was fabulous we had a great
time and and we just outgrew it yeah you
know
it's a great thing you know we're we're
so happy that that has gotten to the
point where we're going to t-mobile okay
you know it's pretty cool venue
september 8th at t-mobile and there's a
lot of other fun things planned we have
mystic mona coming out there's so many
things really quickly normal where can
people get tickets if they want to come
go straight to our website
www.dfssouthernevada.org and get your
tickets from 50 to 125 dollar package
and you can win to participate in all
these events the tickets include the
ability to participate in our dig
amazing i'm so excited so honored to be
a part of it so thank you ladies for
being here i can't wait to see you on
september 8th mercedes will send it over
to you